people now a disturbing Discovery after
our 8 news now investigators first told
you about this a County contractor
finding this Barrel opening it up and
finding human remains inside
and a good afternoon to you thanks for
joining us at five I'm Brian Loftus I'm
Denise Valdez new evidence in this
murder case revealing what led police to
their suspect eight news now
investigator David charns broke this
story David in studio and David what are
you learning police and prosecutors
believe this murder suspect allegedly
killed his victim because he believed
that man snitched on him and his group
of friends to police now police suspect
while he was in jail on another charge
he alluded to doing something police
hadn't yet caught him for we do want to
warn you some of the images in this
story are graphic
an incarcerated individual at Clark
County Detention Center it's what
prosecutors say 43 year old Ryan Bentley
said in jail phone calls that led to his
arrest for murder
Bentley was in custody on a drug charge
police suspecting by then he had already
allegedly shot and killed 39-year-old
Renee Enriquez Jr his body later found
in this Barrel
what
Angelica called you yes yes prosecutors
say Angelica is 30 year old Angelica
Hudson police arresting her in December
but prosecutors soon dismissed her case
photos presented to a grand jury show
bullet holes at Bentley's home near
Washington in Rainbow after the reported
shooting prosecutors say Bentley sent
various Facebook messages about
chemicals and a large drum on October
29th police say he sent this I either
need new Sawzall blades or cash apps so
I can ride bike to buy some documents
the eight news now investigators
obtained last year say a public works
contractor would later find enriquez's
Body in this 55-gallon Barrel on
November 29th prosecutors say Bentley
sent more messages leading up to that
Discovery bro the expletive me and her
had to do compared with cartel videos
one message said I was in real situation
I can't talk about and all I needed was
few gallons of hot water I just needed
hot water to activate the lye the
coroner's office later identifying the
victim's decomposing remains from his
tattoos lye of course is used in is a
chemical used in decomposition Bentley
is doing court on that charge later this
month and due to that murder charge a
judge is holding him without any bail
I'm David charns 8 News Now
so as David mentioned metro police
arrested Angelica Hudson on murder
charges connecting to this case back in
December but prosecutors have since
dropped all charges against her